Hello
, welcome to sts.
I am
Lee Bo-hyun, who is in charge of head training in the Resident Korea 2
cs team. Nice to meet you.
What I will introduce today
is fpc 2 tip n2
.
Let's find out about
uh, the contents here are the contents that my brother checks once
before driving the system every day
.
First,
let's take a
look at what is there.  Hit it first and
have a warm-up time of about 20 to 30 minutes
.
Then, you can use it today, so
you chat about the amount of solvent transfer. The
solvent that can be used at this time is Mobile
Belize Games Worship 2 Jamsil Wash
Yes You
can just check the amount. Do you think it will
work?
Then, after using that amount of solvent
, there will definitely be waste
, so
check if there is still overflow in the waste container.
It is also important to prevent unpleasant situations from occurring
.
Then, the pump is
putt.  Then you can
make it the same as
me. Then, the sample you prepared the day before
or the sample you did all 11 No
*
Example of the
sample to be analyzed
now  Finally,
before using food stamps or turning something like this, you should check that the
pressure or ripple of the system is
within the normal range, and
then activate the drink.  The important and basic
thing is now the column,
so let's take a look at the contents of
this column. What is this column? What is the
hpc color? The direction of its flow
is marked on the surface of the column.
You have to
confirm it once.
Next, the column company should have
a guideline that users of A Guide 1 can use.
It is related to avoiding column 2, but in the 20s of the column volume
,
ah, 10 times acid, about 20 times.
Episode 4
Pure fish
water or organic solvents that do not go into the buffer before cooling down are first
stabilized by flowing more through the column, and
then the solvent that makes it the base
is
finally flowed through the color to
stabilize
it.  Next,
you use a lot of guard columns to protect this column a lot.
Yes, this is also a
reference to the sample and matrix.
The next time you store the column for a long time, do not
store it while it is installed in the system. If
you look at
the reed of the column remains
, it is the analogy of the solvent to be used in the charging used when storing it
.  The
best way to use it is to remove it and restore it
by filling it with
the solvent commanded below.
according to de  I
think you can use it properly for some reason.
And
I hope you don't open Asia much more. Once you
open it again,
no matter how tight you tighten the column, yes, the column packing
material touches it and comes out finely, or
it looks like this, so you can't use it.
If possible, it
would be better if you do not open the column.
Then, this time, I will take a look at
the fittings that are connected to the column or complete system.
I've shrunk the galaxy a bit, but
these fitting companies have a more similar fitting size.
Well, if you look here
, the protruding parts in front of the nut are
different for each company.
If
you use our privilege to write and
use the Waters column for the Um column, in
this case, the
Waters color is
suitable for the Waters column because the Waters company has its own head fittings in the morning,
but our company is 2 2
Elant does not come out separately, but it brings in Suradulak products and builds them
to fit the hard rock products of Yosu
. So, if we know the system well, which column is
cheaper?
There will be a difference. So, because it
is given to Australia of this type in the figure
below, please analyze the teacher's analysis
.
If you know all of these fitting sizes when connecting columns for each company, you can prevent this kind of
leak or this kind of loading peak offloading in
advance.
One came out about development,
but this is a 2-line fitting.
A-line fitting
, this part is hand tight,
so it is turned off by Joe. So,
tighten the head title and look here, the clasp is
out.
Well, in
addition to the system, it is an upt that can withstand up to 1300 outside
. Usually, the plastic plastic note that can
be used as a peak teabing that we can use as a hand titer
can
not withstand
more
than 200 once tightened.  In the system, this is the
idea of
the construction
beaker.
This is
a product that came out very well. If
you use the a line pqr,
it is the answer I explained
before
.  If
you use Lal Bay Light, you can solve it once.
Then, the fittings supplied by us in our gel art
are equipped with this color d. 2 colors that
stand out mean the inner diameter of the two tubes.
Usually, red
0.12 is the next
I am using the fem 0.17 s size.
4 Precautions The arm is the hps and the hpc used by itself, and
the teabing is
1 size, and the
basic specification is to connect everything from other pumps to d tf.
Oh, 0.12 pairs of red ones.  If
you used this red one,
it's better to touch it and set it up. It's better to set it up with a journal that is already a great job position. In the
middle, use 0.17 from the pump to the column
and use 0.17 from the column end to
the detect.
If you use 11 or vice versa
, the following problems occur when you can use
it.
For example, if you use
spiritual with a small inner diameter from the previous pump to the color,
and use 0.17 when it comes out from the end of the column to the detector,
it suddenly widens, etc.
In this way, it is possible to pick
up on the back or get buried, or
3 of these can occur, so
now
it is better to match the size to the sound fitting if possible.
Then, the Mobile Days 2 mobile
page is very basic but
very important, most of the teachers
Even if you're a little busy, you're
just digging and using a few skis,
or getting hit and embracing the foreground a little
often,
so you kept what's in the swearing guidelines as much as
possible.
So, this channel is basically
used as a mobile page through Aqua Crab.
Then
4 If you look at the color of the bottle here, it has a transparent color
. Yes, there is a brown bottle.
In the case of solvents with
such components that become polymer heavy pressure
,
yes
, you can use a brown bottle to prevent that by
blocking some light.  It
is better to prepare the solvent fresh every day. After
that, you need to
use a filter so that the vent can be used all the time
.
Well, then, do
you basically use two or more mobile pages? Basically, genius
conditions should be well mixed. Then this
3t should be good.
There is already a Benteke in the dragon pulse field. There is a peeler
. So
that it doesn't get clogged now
.
If you do this, you
can prevent something that is blocked by the high filter rate.
Then, what you always prepare for yourself
is
that the teachers have more experience than me, so you must have
lived well.
If you use something
with a slightly weaker
sole vent and melt the jjambab,
etc., it will be difficult to see, so avoid
this kind of thing as much as possible,
and then
prepare at least
the minimum amount of sample prepared
.
Then, one of the chapel deputies  The
third is that before the sample rim feels Levi,
you must filter the sample through the
yes camp filter and through this syringe filter.
You may lose or cause this kind of problem.
Hey, then you
ask about putting,
but putting is not that difficult. In the end,
fuzzing is the hpc you used the day before
.
The line we used now has a
little bit of solvent, and
it's a job to get rid of the air inside
.  Open the purge valve,
but do
100% for each channel.
Some gods here say
50:50 or 80:20
or change the
field to 5ml Roman as the first condition of using
that method and spread it.
So you will be vain  At that time, I will give notice No. 4 that each channel does 5 minutes of
wall burns
c at least 5 minutes for
purging.  The waist line is a
projection line. From the transparent
line, until the law doesn't come
out, until it doesn't go out,
you can think of it as the basic point.
5 minutes is a mythical law
.
It is most accurate if you remember that it is the minimum
oven or the fuzz valve l
until the bubble does not come out from the waistline side. Then, when the
puzzle is
over and you catch the pulp, 6 new pieces are
made into color, so now the
stabilization field is gradually now  It'll be stable
Then, when it's stabilized, you'll have to see the
pressure remaining ripple U
Taipei The detector consciousness
sees three things like the r baseline,
yes you can see it when all three are stabilized.
And food can be thought of as a pulse generated when the pump is
now in a Mac analog state and
the two pisters go back and forth
. How do you know that the pressure fluctuates up and down?
You can
see it as Sochi for giving.
You can check it in the requirements software.
Yo pump on Sword Status
window Click the box-shaped icon here in the upper right corner of the pump to
expand it like
this.  If 5 is less than plus or minus 2%
, yes, it is normal
How stable it is in the pressure arm It
doesn't shake Then the base
eye is also Is Here, the baseline noise
refers to the signal from the detector
Then, before the time below is accurate,
then the area
interview value is limited. Once the
peak height value is also reproducible
I'm going
to bother teachers a lot with these terms.
First of all, when a problem with pressure occurs,
you can
compress the three problems as follows
.  If it shakes too much,
let's take a look at it in three ways.
If you look at it, yes,
when it becomes orange soft water,
yes,
the columns are getting better.
It's because the conraum sound
side is contaminated, or in this case, the
pressure rises a lot.
Then
, there is a filter that is the first step in the process of being purged.
You have to do it to the extent of replacing the rhythm. So,
without taking out the pristine, now it's clogged, but it's not clogged, but you can do it
.
Let me give you a simple tip
Yes, if it is more than 10 rounds, the freeship is
blocked. The
standard I just mentioned is
when the purge valve is opened in the case of the old 1200 series l.
Yes, this reduces the
grip to near zero
.
It's
gotten a little better, so if you think of it
as a puzzle, it doesn't fall as a reverse material
.
You have to use it. You can press it to
book
it. Then, all sorts of kettles, no,
that color, moss, yes,
tubings, etc. Such features.
Rotor misstep 2
Yes,
what is
it?
Now, when the pressure drops,
it is the most common. So, in the
case of yogurt like yin and yo, nicks appear
and 4 pressure drops
at the same time, so two at the same time.
If q is revealed,
it
does not go up well in the
solvent.
You know,
uh, I obviously have a method on a 9 this
channel, so I turned it to a chicken
first, before I used something else,
5a and be another stage for another channel,
from now on  Dean, I
press it without knowing that it is filled through other solvents.
News Plant sees all the salts that do not fit my method.
Hello, it will be strange.
Then, yes, the flow rate
.
When you look at it, the fuzz valve is
completely detected, and in
this case, the pressure drops a lot.
Then,
for those who use Heo-tang pumps,
there
is a part called the mc part that
mixes the 4 solvents in a ratio. Why is the multi-channel article  It is
said that it
is a matter of proportion why the proportion is a matter of ratio. If you
mix it abnormally,
the pressure will drop.  If
this has been used for a long time and has become very
weak, in this case, the
pressure will rather drop.
Uh, this time, if the pressure fluctuates a lot up and down, it
is not stable
.
If it
is clogged in the filter press pf,
then,
when preparing the solvent, you know the
god of digging, especially in the
case of water, since it
is a solvent that creates a lot of bubbles
.  If you can, you can do
all of the dick s in this character.
Yes,
these are the ones who have done all the sonic in the sonic character differently. No, please do the
machine number node in the sony
kter.
There is something called a font cd that makes it unacceptable here
as the pistons come and go back and forth
, but if the song is
used beyond the standard, the cd is managed
.
getting wider  If it is
widened, a fine leak
occurs. Even when a run link occurs, the arm
becomes unstable. Then
, if the valve with the original high-liquid qb in the outlet is broken, of course, the pressure will be
abnormal.
Eventually, this pressure becomes abnormal, only up and
down  If it is not a hardware problem that the Ian step is canceled, it is
usually
the case that the inside of the pump is filled with air
. So if
you remove this part enough, it will be solved.
At this time, well, you can see the motor self-traffic.
Normal pressure. Yes, usually, the
auto sampler works as the main pass at normal times
.
When the
solvent goes
through the rotor sh rotor c of the aggro rotor valve, then this turbine device,
then the sample loop needle needle c
, the flow path that goes into the column
is the main path. Bypass
is the sample loading  Because it
is now,
I write to keep believing in Taesan in the main pass
. I can't take samples in that state.
I can't see what it's giving.
So between the main passer bypass,
yes, it's normal to
drop about 1 bar from b 3 to about 1
bar while working, but I know that this is too much of a difference than the standard.
It's
blocked somewhere in the table pass
. You can judge it like that. It's
usually the lead round lead cc
. It's the most frequently blocked spot in our service.
Please use mark Please use the
product for this pain.
Then, the reproducibility problem The reproducibility
problem should be divided into two parts.
If the peak interview value becomes strange and there is no woman
yesterday like Yes in this tension,
there is a higher probability that it is more than the Yes Firm side rather than
this Otter Sampler.
In
the case of a problem with no students, well
, I said that the autosampler had a problem earlier, but
which part of the order sample is a
problem?
is the most,
then the external thing is now pro racing in the pump,
it is clear that the ending is
unsettling, and even the resignation when the bass is in an unstable state.
Yes, if the interview
proposal can have a significant impact, it
is possible.
Now, this time,
if there is a problem with the 4 tension time
, you can think of it in three ways.
If or Yes From the
normal range,
if the number of blades comes out as if the zoom is slightly widened, or
if it is
pushed back, you
can think of it by dividing it into three broad categories.
In
some cases, there
is a pest on the color side of a column
.
There are cases like
this, and then there are very two of these, but
now the two cases are the
most problematic, and if the long columns of the column
are damaged,
for example, you need to use about 8 for the
mobile page, but
outside the range of pitch e  If you have raised the mobile fold you are using
, the step at the top will
be weakened.
In
the case of ph on the mobile page
you are using, you must
select and use a color that can be used for the appropriate work used by the
solvent. Then, if the composition of the solvent becomes a
little unclear and wears out
, this is
usually the case now.  There are a lot of
parts that mix the solvent.
If something goes wrong with these parts, the
composition of the medium will change
,
so the pc
actually gave me a command to mix it in a ratio of 60:40 like this, but in reality
I'm talking about a case where you can't stone
like that.  Yes, once
you received the service from us, you
have to check it once.
Then, this time, if the netizen time is pushed to the back,
the
connection is the same in any case.
There are cases like this when you are pulled forward or pushed back. In the case of
salinity, don't worry about it quickly.
Like the splitting of the Red Sea,
the time underneath that splits open like that,
thin now
that
splits like that  If so,
these days, the laboratory is well equipped with constant temperature and humidity
meals.
However, there are quite a few experimental addresses that do not work like this. But,
again, our
country and society go away,
so
what we measured in the spring and what we measured in the summer
are different.  So in
such a case, algae can change for sure. In the case of
will,
if you improve the environment for the experiment
, the symptoms will improve
.
It is commonly known that the Bobo conception should be used with a source of 20 or higher,
but this
was used as a Dia in
case the system was polluted below the standard. Thank you. There must be a
case like this.  On the
mobile page,
I want to use solvents a and b at 3:00 at 3:00, but
there is a tag with Misil looking at whether these
will rot well or mix.
You have to advertise,
and if you can't actually talk about hardware, well,
even if you get a service from more engineers who are professional owners,
yes 2. It
's a good way to test whether it really mixes well.
If you know enough about the alarm
integration and color only, call the column rupees in your
10s to 20s, Thursday 11th,
about 5 times as much as 100 million years.
So
[Music]
20 times the volume of the column 30 times Information
What do
you say
?  in minutes  After stabilizing for about 30 minutes
, time will come out from there.
So it would be nice if you give me
enough time to decide only the color.  It is also the same case if there
is a problem with composition 2 of the
pediatric solvent
.  Teachers can't do this directly
. Yes,
then there are
people who use
this Unfair Reciever.
Quality
So, the
requirement is, if possible,
why do you command to use a reagent with one pair of short, show-class alkyl chains?
Yes, I will give you a reward.
I think it will be solved to some extent. This
time,
if there is a problem with the e10 time in succession, and if there is a hardware problem in the problem,
what part is the problem?
If you like that the mixing was
not done properly in the desired ratio
Yes,
then the active valve Ahn Lab Ball
Valve I have a chance or I am a professional
lacey experiment from the beginning to the end of the 1st episode
Melo firepower, even in my dreams, this is a
hot topic  In
fact, if it didn't flow once in real life
, in this case,
it could cause problems in almost pig time.
Then, as Tenpro Choa
said, the monitoring environment part Well
, based on his experience so far, the Conn of Clan is
minutes apart.  I'll ruin it, temperature
control  I haven't seen a case where the troll is more than this
.
Most of them were influenced a lot by non-experimental parts, so I
've seen such a case, but if
you open a little goal,
I think you can prevent such a problem in advance at Eri Pension Time.
Then  In the case of a mini let problem
like this,
uh, the main purpose of using the indicator thread for everyone usually
is to decree, so you
have to quantify it. 4 This is a problem related to quantification.
Then, the
white problem is the most complete service
experience, 1 8 90% of the auto sampler guns
have a lot of problems,
as before, Lotus
1, m, Levi's, Siri,
then, believe Red Sea
.
Well, it can be real and the problem is the detector
Gaboni, but
isn't the detector itself a problem? Since
the concentration of the sample and the ampoule manager are not responsible
, if this exceeds
the maximum that the detector detects,
then we will do it to a specialist
Yes, I use that term a lot,
but the set will
cause the occurrence. If it is an oral, yes, you
can improve the concentration to a lower concentration and
install it again.
Now, this is mass line noise.
Most of them have some misunderstandings, so
if I tell you once again, if it gets higher,
it's noise
. The pop noise and
drift are the
same concept.
Deyo When you actually go there, what kind of problem is Face
Ra L A Well like this
Yes go up or
go down.
you have to
As those who have noticed, the noise is a
short term. What happens to the
baseline when sending such a short period of time
? The
drift is a long
flop.  If you look at it, Io is explained well,
so try it once with reference to May
. Uh, Noh Hee-ji and Drift are the same concept, but
that time you see is just a short term,
only one rom hair
.  In some way, it moves
up and down just like the wall while forming a little bit
of
Pyongyang.  This is Drift Guy now, this is
also cool
.
.  Column 5 minutes, 40 degrees
Rosetti, 35 trillion spans with 3 rods, and the
temperature difference is cool. It's a detector
rotor.
It has to bounce
like this Yes If the signals are like this regularly, there
is 1 bubble filled with bubbles inside the cell
. In that case, yes, you have to
drain it enough
.  The only problem out of the detector is the
lamp  Now, the usage time is too long,
or the detector serie is heavily contaminated,
or it is
too high here.
There
is a detector probe shooting in m, which is significantly
different from other models, but there is a save,
if possible, yo oh oh,
if you can check
these things, it is not that difficult.  It seems that there are a lot of people who
always shed green solvent like
this for an
hour or so every time they want
to
cleanly buy the Plot of the plot.
Shooting
is not something that happens. You
really checked the time when you set up the lamp, and
if you just replace
it according to the usage time, it's
not like
that.  I
hate you for doing it, so if you prevent me, yes,
you can produce a character while still attracting the same performance, so it
will give Slade some stress points.
I've given you all the contents. Uh wait, I'm going to
explain a few things for information, but why, if you try the
Gent website, you can get a lot of all the information.  If you look at notes or something like this,
information about new products, you can
go to a website like this and get
these things
.  You're doing well, but now I want
to ask you a favor out of a few old minds.
Now, please
don't tell me with a lot of simple symptoms.
Uh, if you look at that software, there
is a
logbook.  It just registers,
but if you capture those parts and send them an e-mail, or
KakaoTalk,
oppression and more service is sacrificed.
I think I can
go turtle Well, sometimes we now
have a consultation door where we can talk now, and now
there are cases where customers can see things like the
serial number or the firmware version for each model now.
There is a new icon that says information. If we click it,
um um, the firmware version for the form module
and the device test will not come out
.  It's not normal now,
but
when it
normalizes soon, we're preparing a little bit
, but
we're delivering 4 things in mini bursts
to them
.  I do a lot, and then I say that I am
an online instructor-led strongman who started last year
. Thank you for the requirements in real time at the vr tee and give a lecture inside
.
In
advance, the content of the lecture was recorded in advance, and when
the video was uploaded to
the website, the
users could download it and
take a break from the lecture.
Since there is this bursty, we
do not
give lectures with a fixed curriculum, but it is optimized by modifying the contents of the lectures to suit our company
.
I can understand it a bit, but
that's a bit of resignation Just in
line with that, please
ask
me for something like this
.  So
let's pay attention to it. Other
people's Chan is 11 years old.
The fender of Lee Jeong-gyu's workshop is yo qr code.
Yes,
you can apply for a lecture, so I
'll take some sound information in advance.
Then, in lte
bursty, there are four types
of photons for gpc.  Confucius, there are
products, so I know that there are various products, so I am
buying them so that I can find them and go
.
I hope you are healthy.
Thank you for listening to today's lecture.
Thank you.
If you leave a second nue,
I will answer the last question.
Well, there is a survey on the screen.
There are a total of 4 patterns.
I have a question about my drunken spear.
First
, the blast Peter in the rum solvent field is
often damaged. Is there a
way to answer
it?  You asked me a question, but when
I visit Hanon Tetr Sem like this, I see a lot of people with broken pants, such as
Hani's face or publishing
, and a little dreamy Christ.
Losing the solvent must have been
so, but the end of the failure is that q individuals always
have a
lot of problems that can be sold so
toughly, and I will give you some old-fashioned recommendations per person very high.
If you look at the low-altitude blaster, it will go out a little.
So then, Jim Sturgess
, if you have a lot of fans, you will know in a way that you can use it in addition to
batching as a convenient thing in the fan.  You ask
me a lot of questions, and you ask me a lot of questions
. Maybe if
I explain an alternative method tomorrow, how much
will the guidelines be
?
I usually read r&d in
general, Mr. l is now using it as a buffer,
and I believe in splendid
shite.
It's just a little bit left to say, but the color
came on, my wife's buffer, and the dog rock, as a
gift for the year that stretched out more 5 buildings,
but after you put it on your government, the
growth to be used at this time, other than salt and organic solvents, is a 100-fold move.
Im
yes, so when I put my pano on, yes
enough  I
can do it enough that I am doing a drawing now,
usually the time I give you a command
is over, the best by me
yes tag weather love no.
It's only bad.
Each of the 100 stretches mean at the meeting
and at the earth and at the pian's end Bali's
make-up is good
.
A way to do it without giving e that has trish or more Well,
usually, when I say fresh,
I mean pepper,
not a puzzle. In case the filter is clogged, there is an ascent.  You
have to pull it out and keep it in the room once again with your eyes
- there's a lot of work to be done before
100% oo buff wrapped wrapper Henkel
gift
Upper Week Open the door and blow with water one hundred steps Associate the pressure at
that time when the oem 4 flows
usually  1100 1200 Cai Ki-heung
Neither gun The model that came out before the purge
valve fell almost to the material and became a sacrificial
pressure, so it fell.
I liked the method a little bit rather
than the
failure
I mentioned.  If the costume pressure is higher than this Hiba,
that free 2nd episode Martin 5 is
faith. At that time, I removed it myself. I think you can check Journey to the West
.
The Birch Symposium site is closed
until June 30.  It's possible
. Close sessions are not only today's eh
ps course, but also replays to
people from the past 5 years. You can see this up to the age of 30. The
next question is
a user who is using the hplc 1100 series.
It's
a question that can't be done.
Oh, how much pressure does your life take at that time?
You have to make sure you don't check it first.
Guidance When
the pressure under the ugo is completely
blocked, children who can not pick it up are slightly
blocked by the stomach area.
It's an experience.
For example, if you look at it then, there's another way in
and there's another way out. Tubing Yeong-gyu,
yes
.  It's
leaking.  5 out of 10 times I have done the sub shape
is the point.
In this way, if the
pressure is stabilized to some extent,
you can use it after stabilizing it with a solvent that can be
touched.
If not, yes yes,
let's share and replace it
.  The next luck is
to analyze it with the gradient, find the solvent ratio at the point in the peak body, and
try to fix it to that ratio. Then, is
there a reason why the peak does not work?
normal organic front part  Looking at the contents of the question, if you say that the
rice paddy commendation is the 6th ceremony, please
break the udon and put it together at the same time.
If you spill a lot of water or buffer incoming water, the pressure will be high
, and from the second half of the interview scar, you
will reduce the emptying of egg water and
spill a lot of gap 4 views
.  If you look at the
ratio at the time of sitting and
forming, parents look at the picture of the presentation below where there is a picture of the presentation, how much is
the rate coming out later after receiving 5%
?
There's no way to save it
,
so you can
buy it fearfully. I'm trying to fix the ratio of pops out, but there's a way to pay it so that it doesn't pop.
The road of one appearance will be in charge of state
affairs.
I
think it was made like the big bang,
but to do that method,
hmm, you need to turn the column on a little bit of Hwaryeong on-air, like the 6 sheets you used, etc.
In particular
, if you pour a lot of analogy to strong water in between,
the a-gps of the US Jung-in color only
- 2 units, then the new
rag prophesied stop is a lot of herpes
.
When the will is
injected, the substance that the brother-in-law and
I lack is full ice.
There are Maya, or lawmakers, in the high layout table, but
they stay
in the column because of mutual interaction with each other.
Then, the empty hit said that the water rate leaked from the second half.
1005 Intel The thing I did is gone
, so I got out of high school with a lot of body right away
.
The situation froze
, and it was after Goren. Actually, to
put it bluntly,
when Yu-kyung's presidency was not far behind, it was
usually achieved at most, so all kitties
should come out in
the book.
I don't know if you've answered this kind of main thought subconsciously.
4 If you have any additional questions
, please post them in the chat window. If you look at
our bur iron heart fur 3 mother's site, you
can now wear clothes
. There is a software center in the bottom menu.
You can find information on the software related to the SAT
graphene super age analyzer. If you leave
any questions, my specialist will answer them. There is a questionnaire in the
lobby.
I have the
following question Is there
a way to do digging other than the hand application device
?
There's something like that gang hair
that goes ahead and walks Helium May Young-ja I
give you?
Yes 10 years old technology feeder does
not have much effect
Uh money is not an
improvement silver effector but
you did a mechanical mode on the
soni kter You know the mod well and if you ask ning again in your kt
nuk trilogy is not enough break your head it  If you do, the
solvent will change
. Compared to your bonnie character,
the most of the ways to do the module. We'll do the
backhoe men these days. What else do you do
?
This makes
it less efficient than fresh compared
to our kt.  If
you have it, please use the chat, and
I think I can give you a quick answer. The
shape is that I answered the question once, but I don't
think you have 4 additional questions.
If you don't have any more questions,
I
'll greet you with this today.
Thank you de Tibbers Chain for participating in the symposium.